cela fait déjà deux semaines qu'à
l'atelier roydor on se prépare pour la
traditionnelle galette des rois
ils font des aisselles réajuster les
recettes le but offrir une galette de
qualité pour les clients après les fêtes
de fin d'année on ne connaît bien cette
période on est rapide donc on sait faire
on s'adapte on s'organise pour pouvoir
faire des choses en temps et en heure et
ça se passe bien les gens les savent ici
pourquoi ils viennent parce que parce
qu'on a on n'utilise que des produits de
qualité qu'on a des maîtres pâtissiers
qui ont une grande expérience dans ce
domaine et que le résultat final il est
il et il est incomparable
la boulangerie roydor confectionne
cinghalais tous les jours pour
satisfaire la clientèle une clientèle
pour qui la galette des rois tient une
place importante est le maître mot est
la qualité avant tout par rapport à
l'histoire et où
11 origines de cette fête des fromages
je trouve que c'est c'est très agréable
de se réunir autour d'une bonne galette
des rois en groupe sur le plan aussi
bien professionnel qu'en famille
voilà la période de la galette des rois
représente 10% du chiffre d'affaires
annuel de la boulangerie roydor